welcome to Hell House in it shall
continue until every would most people
assume wind is the only thing that blows
[Music]
[Music]
all right cool fine normal the
documentary
[Music]
this thing's not really a ticking time
bomb is it I don't know I couldn't place
for sure it was a little bit different
than that it'll be quieter you're
disturbing the dead okay plastic because
I can't hear you what Oh Melissa I want
the wind just open it they came in and
for three days continued for three days
they continued can you shut the [ __ ] up
I hate outside can we go inside yeah we
go back in the back door lock yeah why
keep us see the containers on the inside
of that one why people live in houses
I'm not talking about every house I'm
talking about specifically your how you
have a go you have a ghost in your house
can we just let the door open and let it
out all right yeah what do you know
reliving our horrible traumatizing year
and I found more damage in the house I
can't see it right now oh no water
heater don't need to see it you just
need to feel it
don't feel it it's hot waters you all
know what it's called because hot on the
inside there's something's hot on the
inside it's hot on the outside feel me
do I feel me like everything else in
this house has made me feel it can't
just be a simple fix
could you just come and replace one fart
don't ask you some questions and they
may be difficult for you to answer but
you need to I wanna do this you were
drowning in non-natural water and now
you find yourself driving your own sweat
the house has a cruel way of showing how
powerful it can be if it's not gonna
drown you in your own excrement it'll
drown you in your own sweat I don't even
know I don't want to think about what
might come next I wish I could rule that
out like I really wish it could we get
like a priest
exorcise the house man you've got better
let's go to the basement
ghosts predominantly hot stupid people
aliens predominantly abduct stupid
people
I'm not you've got plenty of company
[Music]
three the drip
he put his finger through the sin that
was the same instance we replace the
pipe the plumber had to come back to
replace the pipe again a second time we
drywall didn't it dripped is that two
separate instances or one the last one
was one drywall and drip that's one yeah
I'm at four year at five I was counting
the whole time well anyway it was
dripping again so at six no this is
still the fourth or fifth drywalled n
dripped and it's still only the fifth
yeah what's the next one thing staying
on the reason that jerk this time was
that mothers of stone the toilet it was
all the toilet upstairs but that's what
was causing all this at six I don't know
anymore
your counting is very advanced i blended
why someone's kind of getting me all
riled up with my counting sorry I sleep
I don't know why you keep doing that I
say goodbye
[Music]